oh that's her on the left there she
looks like uh
an extra from uh
that thrift shop song with macklemore
yeah
what what what she looks like um
cruella de vil a little bit yeah she
looks like she got about 30 dalmatians
bruh
she's a she's a traveling rn an avid
thrift shopper
and i knew it she's a beautiful auntie
of two teenage daughters
of this lady right in the blind yeah
wait the one on the far right we're
talking about the mamacita the thrift
store
the three yes she's the aunt and the one
who sent it in is the blonde woman
that's her sister
that thrift store vixen it's rare you
get a thrift store vixen in this [ __ ]
beautiful and this is flaunt my aunt oh
yeah this is goodwill's finest
and is that real fur do we know if
that's fake what is that alpaca
mogadishu what is that
it's about as real as that waiters
toupee that thing is
fake as [ __ ] and is that crown real is
she of royal descent
that's a good question them lips are
real though
brendan of some respect is a woman well
there's a lot of fakeness going around
these days i'm proud of her
what else can you say about this girl
derek uh
i i like her jacket game of thrones vibe
going like the mother of bad jackets or
something you know what i mean yeah
you ever been in a thrift store oh yeah
when i was little my dad used to bring
me my brother in there every saturday
and like say you can pick one
thing i used to get one ski sometimes oh
wow
pretty strong just a random baseball
card some days
i used to get a vase or like a plate
sometime i get a high heel
yeah why not um yeah she seemed like
kind of italian she's got that faint is
this rip my drip
flop flaunt mine yeah look i'd be her
little nephew
you know i would definitely come out of
her sister's vagina if she needed me to
and i think she's that coat is pretty
sexy
she has a sexy goodwill vibe i'd buy her
a used jacket or some [ __ ] if she wanted
yeah you got to get that coat pressure
washed though i you know if you get any
furs and that's rule number one if you
get any furs out of a 99
cent shop or half or salvation shop you
got to pressure wash that [ __ ]
you got to yeah you don't just and you
don't put it in the washing machine you
need to
really hit that thing right there where
the follicles
hit with the hot water you have no idea
what's been in there yeah and you could
even boil that [ __ ] obviously and then
drink a little bit out of the
pot and just taste if you taste
something [ __ ] foreign or a little
bit of paint
because most people ain't giving up
their mink coat to the goodwill
unless it has some bad juice on it yeah
or some murder happening that's what i'm
saying that mafia murder gives those up
yeah so that's could be that might be a
new jersey
goodwill yeah she got that jon snow
though she got that janice snow cone
look
and i'm not mad or she yeah she's got
some nice lips
her face looks like nice
she has a nice arm you can't see that
other arm she's a goodwill model bro
yeah they call it goodwill out here or
do you call it the ark out in l.a where
anyone know what the ark is in aurora we
call it the ark
the ark it's called the ark it's another
discount place oh no out here it's
buffalo exchange and goodwill goodwill
salvation army that's it i think
and i think the salvation army we should
let them fight whoever you know what i'm
saying brother
release the hounds i don't want to sin
protect the borders
stench only bro throughout throwing old
paintings at people they could [ __ ]
win in a heartbeat
throwing old tennis rackets at people
bro you want the serenity prayer
you go to dang uh you go to the
salvation army
all right let's keep it cruising huh
[Music]
is